stefan doernberg wird hier in berlin
geboren sein vater ist jüdischer
kommunist als er elf jahre alt ist
fliehen seine eltern mit ihm vor den
nazis in die sowjetunion
sechs jahre später am 22 juni 1941
meldet sich dörnberg freiwillig zur
roten armee
es ist der tag an dem die deutsche
wehrmacht die sowjetunion überfällt als
ich dir krieg dem ende nähert betritt
dörnberg als leutnant zum ersten mal
nach zehn jahren wieder den boden seiner
heimatstadt seine einheit hat hier in
berlin einen spezialauftrag ein
akustisches täuschungsmanöver die
deutschen truppen sollen bewusst in die
irre geführt werden
musik-fans die panne besser als musik
wie weit tragen deine lautsprecher
genosse leute nannte drei kilometer
mindestens wenn der wind richtig steht
vielleicht noch weiter dreimal vorlauf
akustische kriegsführung
kein schlechter dreht die wand gefahren
genuss und du musst noch die deutschen
messen als wir
ich bin deutscher
in vielen stadtteilen noch erbittert
gekämpft wird hat die rote armee einige
randbezirke berlins bereits besitzt ihr
braucht keine angst mehr zu haben
der krieg ist für euch vorbei für den
hitler faschismus ist er schon lange
verloren
jeder widerstand ist zwecklos die rote
armee ist gekommen um euch zu befreien
der hitler faschismus hat ganz europa
und die ganze welt ins unglück gestürzt
nun ist es an der zeit ein neues ein
besseres deutschland aufzubauen
darauf haben wir seit jahren gewartet
genauso leuten an seit heute dienstag
den 24
april 1945 ist generaloberst bersani
stadtkommandant von berlin aber in
berlin wird noch gekämpft genauso
leugnen der erste befehl des
stadtkommandanten lautet
erstens die bevölkerung der stadt hat
volle ordnung zu bewahren und an ihren
wohnsitzen zu verbleiben
zweitens die nationalsozialistische
deutsche arbeiterpartei und alle hier
unterstellten organisationen sind
aufzulösen
ihre tätigkeit wird hier mit verboten
elfter verbände der roten armee und
einzelne militärangehörige die in berlin
eintreffen sind verpflichtet nur erwähnt
von den militärischen bezirks und revier
kommandanten angewiesenen unterkünften
quartier zunehmend angehörigen der roten
armee ist ohne erlaubnis der
militärischen kommandanten die
eigenmächtige aussiedlung oder
umsiedlung der einwohner entnahme von
gütern und werten und hausdurchsuchungen
bei den stark einwohnern verboten woher
sprechen sie so gut deutsch ich bin hier
geboren aber das ist eine lange
geschichte
ich war ja immer gegen die nazis als
alter sozialdemokrat menschen die mich
brauchen sie jetzt
hier ist der vorsitzende der spd vor
1933 das war der also mir liegt es auf
der zunge
will
obwohl
aktion
den kampf
es erscheint wasser jede stunde
wir meinen
unserer verwundet jeder der jetzt noch
im kampf um berlin fällt bringt sein
opfer umsonst
im einvernehmen
mit dem oberkommando der sowjetischen
truppen
von daher auf
sofort den kampf einzustellen
schnitt
mai
der artillerie
nach der kapitulation berlins arbeitet
stefan doernberg für die sowjetische
militäradministration in mecklenburg er
studiert geschichte in moskau und
ost-berlin und wird einer der
bekanntesten historiker der ddr in den
80er jahren wirkt er als botschafter im
finder